this is a production of Cornell
University
so I lifted this photo from the New York
Times this morning and the reason I put
it in here is because it reminds me when
things don't go right why I keep doing
this so this was in India and it says
when rains fail it compounds other
problems this year a pest infestation
and maharashtra combined with drought
devastated the millah in corn in india
so that's why I keep doing this and so
what I want to talk about today is I
realized I hadn't really talked too much
about what I've done in the last several
years and that's look at the pin victims
it Vin's axes annoyed pathway these are
major defense compounds in some cereals
but not all of them and you can see the
different types of insects is annoyed x'
and their acronyms depicted below and
they're found in maize wheat and to some
extent in rye and barley but they're not
found in rice Oh cultivate of barley or
sorghum they might play other roles
within the plant such as signaling and
here's where all the genes involved in
the bends axes the noid pathway are
located on the ten chromosomes in maize
you can see a couple things looking at
this the letter A there's a small gene
cluster there which is important yeah
I'm going to talk mostly about that
cluster in this talk and then there's
another cluster on chromosome 4 which is
which is depicted by the letter F which
is the core fins X's NR gene cluster B X
1 through B X 5 here's the pathway they
all everything's derived from I three PG
up here which leads to indole in one of
three branches one ultimately goes to
tryptophan one makes volatile well it
makes endo which is going to turn into
volatile and then the other endl is the
Corbin's ox is annoyed pathway that i'll
talk about so this part of the pathway
happens in the chloroplasts and then
there's four mono oxygenase is that lead
to the first toxic compound die Bella
and that's ultimately decorated a little
bit more in the cytoplasm into these
other toxic compounds and eventually
transported into the vacuole in
particular they're they're all
glycosylated you'll notice there's a
sugar a glucose on each end of that and
that prevents ototoxicity in the plant
so I'm going to the rest of the talk I'm
going to focus on this part of the
pathway where BX 10 11 12 and 14 can
catalyze the conversion of dimbo
glucoside to h2 vogel side which are two
of the most toxic compounds in the
pathway B X 10 and 11 are induced upon a
liver or bibury and B X 12 is
constitutive the X 14 is it can accept
in boa a glycoside as a substrate but
it's not known exactly how much it
converts it into HTML like relative to
the other two okay so upon
what happens is that issue gets me a
serrated and you lose the membranes of
the chloroplast and the vacuole and what
that does is because there's glucoside
aces stored in the chloroplasts and they
cleave the sugar off of the dimbo
glucoside and h2 boa glucoside which
leads to the toxic compounds dim boa and
HTM boa so the pictures here represent
what they do to aphids if you have dim
boa
even though HTM boa is more toxic Timbo
uh Timbo induces the formation of Kalos
which is a polysaccharide which prevents
the aphids from sticking their stylus
into the plant so you actually get fewer
aphids
if the pathway is blocked here then if
it goes all the way it makes the more
toxic compound the opposite is true of
caterpillars because it's more toxic if
the pathway is blocked here the
caterpillars do better
we're dimbo is and worse if it goes all
the way to h2 boa the more toxic
compound so a few years back in our lab
we are a natural transposon knockout was
found in dx12 and what what just to take
away from here is if that you get the
transposon knockout it blocks that
conversion from dim boa to HTM boa and
you get dimbo here so the aphids do
worse and if it goes if the gene doesn't
have the transposon the aphids do or the
caterpillars do worse so that's that's
the trade-off between the aphids and the
caterpillars dope piercing insects
versus chewing insects opposite effects
this was a paper that came out just last
year and note that things are flipped
here and they also grouped the name
founders into their respective tropical
temperate or mixed origins so what they
did in the top is they replicated what
was done in our lab and they they
basically confirmed what we saw
in the bottom they added several
teosinte accessions the ancestors of
ancestor of maize and what they found
out is none of the teosinte accessions
had the transposon knock out blocking
the pathway so that excited me because
prior to this Oh so the other thing that
they found in this paper was that the
nucleotide diversity differed around the
transposon on both sides and in teosinte
who is more diverse and moving from
tropical to temperate maze there was
less and less nucleotide diversity
around the insertion indicating that
this was probably a target of selection
either directly or indirectly but what
you'll notice is that the transposon
does not segregate with all temperate
inbreds which is kind of weird so that
suggests that it wasn't ancestral and
that the diversion this transposon event
happens sometime
after tropical and temperate diverged
and then diverged within the tropical as
maize was expanding its range meanwhile
my advisor was in Mexico and he had
collected 214 teosinte accessions from
la [ __ ] that happened to be growing there
he sampled 2 plants per accession and
brought him back to me to make extract
DNA so I did some PCR and I found the
transposon in 8 no 9 out of the 214 I'd
screened represented on the bottom here
and of one of the perfect limits lines
so I was excited about this because this
refuted the information in the paper
right and that its ancestral and wasn't
didn't the transposon event didn't
happen during domestication and
confirmed in my sequencing it was real
so I ordered the teosinte accessions
from CIMMYT and I also found some
teosinte in my seed core that I sort of
threw in his controls a couple different
lines and then importantly also the
Doble lines that were I had a little bit
of the seed from the double lines that
were in the paper one thing you'll
notice though is that a lot of these
came from the same place in elevation
and al Bataan so I move forward and I
planted these things EF Senate
germination is known to be generally
poor and variable W lab recommends
chipping the seed but when I tried that
teosinte seed went flying and it would
have been too much work so I tried three
germination methods on paper towels in a
petri dish and vibed in water overnight
and I directly sewed them in pots and
luckily directly sewing the pots worked
the best I got the best germination so I
move forward with my a phat bioassay
I planted six seeds of each of each
accession an aphid performance by OSA
transferred the seedlings to a chamber
of fifteen days after planting and then
I caged the aphids using plastic bread
bags and then as I infested the plants I
can currently harvested two tissue
samples one for DNA extraction to
confirm the insertion in the plants and
then one for downstream pens access
denied' profiling and I love the efforts
to feed on the planet for one week
before scoring a third survivorship and
become 2g meanwhile I'll extract the DNA
and perform PCR but the primers I used
to confirm da Pia insertion the
transposon I couldn't recover any of
them in Simek lines here are my controls
the original PCR amplicons I generated
from the DNA that George collected and
so when I try to
by the wild-type allele you can see I
amplified it in just about everything
indicating that this was probably a
heterozygous insertion meaning it's
probably not fixed in the teosinte is
what I took away with it interestingly
there's a couple of polymorphisms here
which indicate that something's going on
in teosinte it's not just the the
alleles can be different at least so
yeah and then I got my a week later I
went back and looked at my a feds my
results and all the aphids were dead on
all my CIMMYT lines but the a that
survived and reproduced on the Doble
lines and the BTI lines that I threw in
for it control so I went back to the
seed envelopes I looked at them and I
found this red residue on here yeah I
wrote the CIMMYT and they confirm that
they treat the seed with a systemic
insecticide to resist pestering growth
so double-whammy so my conclusion is
teosinte readily hybridizes with maize
the initial PCR results are probably the
result of admixture in teosinte seed
that are the teosinte plants that George
had collected in Mexico so I'm not going
to move forward with this anymore
one thing I could do is all these
teosinte lines have dart C data at
CIMMYT and I could look for evidence of
snip polymorphisms between modern maize
and teosinte to nail it down but I don't
think it's worth it so here's a little
afterward there's still variation in
those X's enoyed accumulation in the
NAMM founders that effects a third
performance and it's not across the
board it's it's variable so I decided to
sequence across the gene using CML 2:47
sequence that's available at maze gdb
design primers to it amplified across it
and as expected all the symmetries lines
amplified the Foley gene
along with the North Carolina lines
which are from a tropical background
themselves the weird one was tz8
which looks like it has some sort of
deletion in the background and yet if
you look at panel B and panel C on the
right it's still converting some dim boa
glucoside to HTM boa glucoside so that's
weird so the question is there is one of
the other benefits access annoyed
paralogs that are normally induced
compensating for that constitutively and
with that I'd like to thank everybody my
committee Denise down at CIMMYT Rory
Sawyer's now at Penn State formerly of
lund hey Bo almighty a funding to keep
my life going the green house staff and
gender labs and of course synapses
thanks everybody
[Applause]
questions time for a few questions yeah
yeah so Mike is asking what was like
going for I'm looking for the kalos to
kill the caterpillar oh that's not quite
right so when you have the bee x12
knockout it induces Kalos which prevents
Athens from feeding on them I'm kind of
in my work is a lot of you know I've
been working with far armyworm as well
and so I'm more interested in the intact
gene and the question was really this
was more of a when did this transposon
thing arise sort of question that was a
that was kind of what I was going for
but really what I would want is to find
lines that have the
that don't have the transposon that make
more HTM boa that could prevent a
caterpillar or bevery
and my main work we have time for one
more quick question if anyone has
if not let's give
have another round of applause and this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu